hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over a chest tactic that
everyone needs to be aware of and that
is the blockade and that typically is
going to refer to stopping your opponent
pushing pawns to advantageous squares
many times that's gonna be a passed pawn
but it's not always gonna be a passed
pawn so we'll look at different examples
of what that would look like in this
case white does have a passed pawn here
on e5 they're gonna be looking to push
that up the board they do have support
with their queen and their rook and if
you look from black standpoint two
things to keep in mind one black does
need to stop this pawn from pushing
forward but it also has different
options you can bring us look here to e6
you can bring us Queen here to e6 and
you can also bring your knight here to
e6 so one you need to always be looking
for blockades and the second one is
understanding the best pieces to use for
a blockade and Knights generally you're
going to be the best especially if you
compare those two rook saying Queens
especially for a passed pawn this is not
only blocking the pond but also the
knight does a good job of being able to
hop over pieces it can still control a
lot of the board even being here on e6
if the rook is here on e6 it can't
really control anything else it's one of
your major pieces and you want that
doing other things on the board well
your night here on e6 doing a good job
of blocking this but still defending and
attacking some of the critical squares
in the center of the board here you're
threatening if this bishop moves you can
come and attack this pawn here on f4 if
you ever need to you can swing over here
to d4 but also just protecting some
other squares on the center of the board
what your rook wouldn't be able to do
and you want your Queen more in the
attacking lanes controlling a lot more
of the board than just being a blockade
sometimes you have to use the Queen but
not always so passed pawns you're
usually gonna be looking to bring your
knight there because the last thing you
want to do is have your opponent start
pushing your pawn up the boar their pawn
up the board and then you're pretty much
stuck you don't have a lot of options
except to put everything behind that to
stop it going up maybe one or two
squares to promote but
every time that you're not gonna be
stopping a passed pawn sometimes you're
gonna be looking just to stop a pawn
from moving its first move in the game
this is a position from a game in the
early 1900s from Nozawa CH who's one of
the the fathers of the hyper modern
openings in chess but had a lot to do
with thinking about the the theory
behind different chess tactics blockade
being one of those that he spent a lot
of time on and in this position he was
white and he recognized that he did not
want to have to deal with black having
any sort of queenside advantage and so
he looked at this and while there's no
past pawns that he had to worry about he
never wanted this pawn to push forward
to a5 which he thought would be a pain
that he would have to deal with maybe
not necessarily right away but at some
point so when he looked at this
he said Bishop to a6 is a great blockade
it stopped this pawn so remember we just
looked at a previous example where we're
stopping a past pun but it's not always
that you need to be thinking about what
pawns your opponent has that you do not
want them to move other pieces on the
board besides the pawn they can move
backwards they can move anywhere they
want to pawns can only move forward and
they can't capture in front of them and
so right in front of them that is and so
we can always be looking at ways to stop
them from moving where they want to now
this limits where this pawn can go to
and it limits some of the squares and
the options that black has on the Queen
side of the board
now beyond finding the best blockade
against your opponent equally is
important to figure out how to stop your
opponent from blockading your own setup
on the board so in this case it's
White's move and you can see white has a
passed pawn here on d6 but we have this
annoying night here on d7 which is
correctly blockaded this pawn right here
but white has a pretty easy job in this
position we'll look at some others that
are not as easy to get rid of this
Knight so the first move would be Knight
to d3 preparing for the knight to come
to c5 and then remove that night there's
no real good square for black to go
he could play King to geez
seven followed by Knight to c5 now black
can't do anything if he moves this night
this pawns just going to push forward
and then it's gonna promote here to d8
and get a queen you can't stop that if
black tries to just capture here the
King's gonna recapture this King is that
now I'm gonna gobble up all these pawns
on the Queen side and have a pretty easy
game to push forward black can't stop it
so I'll may look like even in material
and black has the blockade White's gonna
be looking to find the way to remove
that piece right here at the blockade
and then continue to push the piece
wherever he is trying to do in this case
it's a passed pawn other cases in the
previous example it may just be trying
to get that pawned pushing forward on
the Queen side so he has some sort of
air to to breathe on the Queen side
maybe just pushing a7 to a5 is all black
is trying to do to start to attack his
opponent now that we've covered the
concept of a blockade we can take a look
at a famous game and see how this is
used in practice so this is from 1950s
between Mac sube he was a world champion
versus his opponent Herman Phil Nick
he's playing with the black pieces and
you can see white has a passed pawn
looking to push this on the D file has
some protection behind it with the Queen
and blacks trying to stop that and so he
starts with the move Knight to c4
preparing for 90 d6 and this is
hopefully after a few examples we've
looked at you can see that this is what
black is trying to do now max is trying
to stop this Knight from coming up here
and trying to find in a way to push
forward and he has a few options that he
was looking at here the first one would
see Knight to be 5 this is stopping the
immediate threat of the knight coming to
d6 because then then I could take you
see an exchange and you know white
doesn't really mind if the Queen
stopping this a Knights a much better
Square to stop a passed pawn as we've
talked about if your opponent is using
your their Queen to stop your pawn from
pushing forward that feels like a huge
win so you can start to explore this
little warrants a knight to b5 looks
promising but then you can see that
night to c7 all that kind of stops it
because this is attacking the knight
that and I can't come to DC
right now cuz it would just fall so
what's kind of the waiting move maybe a
for to protect this but then after the
night takes and the pond recaptures you
can't stop the night coming up here to
d6 another option if we look from white
standpoint of how to continue you could
see f4 and you're almost hoping that the
pond takes here and eventually you can
push forward with E 5 at some point and
then push forward with a d6 this seems
like a possibility but black doesn't
have to take instead you could see black
just immediately come up here on d6 and
if the pawn captures the bishop can
recapture here on e5 it's still very
difficult for white to stop what black
is doing now max in the game decided to
try something different looked at those
options and said don't don't think
either those are going to work so
instead he tried to move he started with
the move
b3 now this does not stop the immediate
threat of the knight coming back here to
d6 so he continued with Bishop here to
e3 and then we see pawn to b6 so let it
find the pawn chain on the Queen side of
the board Queen to d2 preparing for the
rook to come over then we work over here
to e8 and then upon to f4 now black
already has the blockade here on d6 now
it's a matter of holding on to the
position so he starts with bringing his
Knight here to c7 definitely doesn't
want it here on the edge here on the a
file so then rook to f2 we see the pawn
take on f4 Bishop takes on f4 Bishop
comes down here to a6 trying to add a
little bit more pressure also opens up
for his rook here on a a to get involved
into the game and then we see rook
swinging over here to e1 now if white
looks at this and says now that my
bishops here on f4 we could actually
take the night here on d6 now this may
look simply good but long-term blacks
still going to have a very good game so
Bishop takes here on d6 and then the
Queen takes here on d6 you could say
well yeah that's exactly what white
would be looking to do and and yes in
the short term but then maybe rook to c1
protecting at this Knight
getting it to a semi-open file but then
rook to e7 and this is preparing for the
night to come here to to e8 so even if
the Queen came to f4 trying to kick this
Queen off
Knight to e eighths and then after if
the Queen's exchange that's fine but now
the knight can easily come to d6 in the
next move and so you can see that black
is still able to control with his rook
with his Queen and then his knight
coming here as well controlling both the
d6 square vitally important to stop the
past pawn from pushing as well as this
square here on e5 as well and this is a
blockade that doesn't have a piece right
away but it is being protected by both
of the rook and the bishop right now
here on e5 so it's stopping both of
these pawns here in the center of the
board
using some some very good moves as well
as just tactics against a world champion
now black because of how he played
specifically with his blockade and
stopping the push in the center the
board went on to win this game so I
thought this would be a good example to
show it in practice of looking at the
board seeing what your pony's trying to
do see if they have pawns that you need
to stop them whether it's a passed pawn
on side of the board or if you just look
at and say hey this pawn is gonna be a
nuisance so I need to stop that at all
cost because maybe if it moves forward
it's gonna kick one of my pieces it's on
a great outpost out out of the way and I
don't want that to happen so always be
looking in your games for ways to stop
your opponent's pawns from pushing
forward to squares that you don't want
them to go so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video on nice little chess tactic
the blockade if you guys have other
strategy or tactics other videos you
want me to make feel free to let me know
best way to reach me is on the website
the chess website calm you can always
chat with me directly there's a chat
functionality on the website you can
always email me at the chess website at
gmail.com but thank you guys so much for
watching I'll see you guys the next
video
you